best new artist from the grammys
right thank you billboard awards you
wikipedia at me no i don't even know
what that is
thank you so much
and then ryrai uh you graduate from high
school yep 2011. that's about it
regional
what's it nasa regional high all right
where is that at cape cod
eastern mass yeah all right went to
college for a couple years
wow
more than me i put in three
where university of tampa florida oh
[ __ ] why didn't you graduate
well i yanked them out yeah no why
didn't you have one more year left it's
good i had like two more years on a five
year basis all right i was not good at
school where did you want to be when you
grew up
i i i still don't know i the major that
worked well was advertising in pr's like
i could [ __ ] yeah so this is this
will work for me and then she was like
don't even bother you could [ __ ] l.a
now when you were in college and was she
blowing up at the time yes um yeah well
the summer i was 21 about to go into
senior year what a great [ __ ] summer
i peaked
how proud were you so proud we played
her song every day at the bar
yeah
you know it's like um
i have a little brother too
right his name is stevie
all right and he's doing well too he is
and there is a pride there
when you when you're a sibling and your
other sibling is doing well there's a
pride there and do you have that pride
for little ryria
[Laughter]
they both live with me both of my
brothers no yeah
that's why he wanted to go
is that why you came what happened no my
little brother wanted to come with us
because last night we were all talking
about like oh my god tomorrow's the best
day of our lives
well he was drunk at harry styles show
and was just like oh bobby lee i [ __ ]
what happened today what happened to
today i don't know man he's kicked into
work here this is a good thing for jacob
i got to do my thing i was like [ __ ] you
then that'll make me i'm proud of you
you know what i you're in with me for
life really yeah you're right you're so
bad little ryria you're in with me for
life
daryl you're in your brother what's your
brother's name gay train justin justin
justin if you're listening to me oh
go [ __ ] yourself
you're out is he the little one yeah
yeah you little you're a little even
littler than ryan
you [ __ ] you betray us we invite you
into our home i had to ask why what do
you say today what do you say today he
he was like well miscommunication then
you should have talked to me hours ago
yeah he's like i i told you at 10 30. i
guess i should have told i should have
told man what's his number
[Music]
he probably won't answer he hates scam
calls it's probably going to come up as
potential spam why
i'm not spam
you love spam unless he thinks maybe
you're one of his doctors or something
yeah i'm his doctor oh yeah dr kobayashi
say that he's gonna hang up hello hi
this is dr kabayashi
uh hey how's it going hi
justin um you had an appointment today
at three you didn't show up
uh
i'm so sorry
doctor who i'm i do not have this in my
calendar i'm so sorry dr kobayashi yeah
i am so sorry if i'm not familiar but
i'm
completely blanking okay well justin you
know you made an appointment a couple of
months ago
we would like to reschedule but we also
want to know what the problem is not
there bobby lee
no justin
justin justin
you know let me say something dude
there's doctor kobayashi here now listen
i've had
so many heartbreaks in my life i've had
three major ones when my dad died
okay
when a girl cheated on me in my early
20s and now you're the third you broke
my [ __ ] heart today justin for not
coming over
i'm so sorry i broke your heart what's
the excuse
this is not my intention what the
[ __ ] excuse
there is no [ __ ] excuse
she asked me that i wanted to go i said
yes i wanted to go yeah today i woke up
it's feeling like [ __ ] and i have a lot
of songs i need to finish i'm gonna walk
these dogs i gotta work out all right
that's enough that's enough for me
i just want to let you know that your
brother ryan told me and it wasn't even
a joke he was saying that you barely
have a penis at all
now what does that mean were you in an
accident
like you were in a motorcycle accident
got ripped off what happened
anyway okay well anyway you don't want
to get into your [ __ ]
your i mean personal [ __ ]
wait what do you say i didn't get that
what do you say what do you say
say it again man i said it can't be any
smaller than me all right
good day sir good day sir dude oh what a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
anyway give him a round of applause
nobody loves you more than justin
trainer i could tell i can tell justin
trainer loves me
right yeah
he loves dr kobayashi
he you don't understand he sees so many
different yeah
because he like recently lost so much
weight but his body's still in shambles
so he's like trying to figure out
physical therapy all of this [ __ ] so
like that was
you got him good i got him good there
you go so good
dying yes who was the gentleman because
he was like oh i'm sorry
he also misses women yeah
dr kobayashi was nice yeah yeah yeah i
didn't feel like he was aggressive at
all i can't believe he didn't understand
yeah
so you're proud of your sister
you better be because she's a pop star
now right i mean just i'm constantly
proud of her right even like having the
kid riley i was just like holy [ __ ] you
did it you're a mom like survived just a
beautiful healthy boy c-section
how did that go not good
tell me what c-section yeah there's
nothing about that oh my god so they cut
you open while you're awake
and then they pull out all your guts and
insides yeah